two weeks after the devastating floods
in western germany more than 70 people
are still missing
the official death toll stands at 181
more than half of the victims died in
germany's r valley
close to belgium these are the latest
pictures
from the town of schultz in some areas
only the foundation walls mark where
buildings once
stood they were either washed away or
had
to be pulled down and this was the scene
in
schultz two weeks ago experts say their
region will need
years to rebuild some households are
still without power
telecommunication and drinking water
supplies
are not yet back to normal everywhere
either
well let's bring in our correspondent
kate brady who is on the ground there in
our viola uh okay dozens are still
missing is there any hope of finding
anyone alive
because there are still people still
missing and uh there are still hopes
that they will
indeed be found alive and well but of
course with every day that goes by both
for authorities and not least of all
for the friends family loved ones of
people who
are still missing it is yet another
difficult day for them and one of the
most
sad challenges facing authorities right
now as well
is that they're finding it very
difficult to identify many of the bodies
that have been
found of course usually it's necessary
to have some kind of material to be able
to do a dna
comparison but given the extent of the
destruction that's been caused to
people's homes and people's belongings
here in these flood-hit regions
that is proving very difficult at the
moment
rebuilding obviously will take years but
what about the more urgent tasks like
restoring
water supply and electricity
well i was talking to some of the uh
disaster
agency aid this morning and they were
saying that step by step bit by bit
many regions are indeed having their
electricity switched back on
and it's uh currently estimated that
around at least 5 thousand
uh people of homes are currently without
electricity
of course that's still uh five thousand
that are
have facing this difficulty every day
but that is
um some huge progress that's been made
in recent days just a few days ago we
were talking about hundreds of thousands
of people without electricity but as you
mentioned water as well especially clean
drinking water that's safe to use that's
also
still an issue and here in arvada for
example thousands of liters of clean
water is currently being
brought in by the disaster agency aid
thw and also
by the german red cross of course in the
meantime
some access to normal water tap water
has been reinstalled and that's been
tested constantly but in
those cases the advice is of course that
that water should indeed be boiled
before use okay i understand there was
some anger as well directed at the
authorities about not having been
forewarned in time and now the slow pace
of reconstruction
what are you hearing what is the vibe
there on the ground
well it's interesting a lot of people
that i've been speaking to residents who
have been
badly affected by these floods many of
them saying they don't understand
some of this frustration that entire
regions are finding themselves in
unprecedented circumstances but
certainly as you mentioned when it came
to the warning system and how early or
rather
late many people were warned if at all
about the impending floods and the
impending danger
and there is certainly still a lot of
frustration there many people asking
could they have been warned earlier
and they're going to be asking a lot of
questions that's already underway
we're seeing in some of these special
commissions that have been set up
in the states uh that have been worst
hit by these floods so there's still a
lot of questions
to be answered and essentially who is
responsible
at least of all could those lives those
lives that have been lost
could they indeed have been saved
uw correspondent kate brady there thank
you very much kate
well homes were flooded complete
livelihoods destroyed
dws tessa walter visited a young syrian
from avila who has
lost everything for the second time in
his life in the
syrian civil war and now in germany
what was once his livelihood is now only
muddy debris
moa made abdul hamid own a small barber
shop in availa
he came to germany as a syrian refugee
now after the floods he's left with
nothing
for the second time in his life
she's been i've been living here in
germany for almost six years now
back in syria i lost everything my house
my store everything i had everything i'd
worked so hard for
and now i've lost it all again
from his balcony the 32 year old filmed
the night of the flooding
mohammed watched people drown
then the water started entering his
building
he reached safety on the second floor
i saw a lot of horrible things from my
window that night
but there was nothing i could do in
syria during the war
at least you could help people but here
i felt so powerless
i could only watch
inside hardly anything of his barbershop
is left
only the mirrors on the wall remain
mohammed had invested over fifty
thousand euros together with a friend
me and my colleague christian we worked
hard to renovate this place
it was really beautiful we put so much
love into it
but now that love is gone
he lost even more the scrap dealer is
picking up mohammed's car
the water has destroyed it completely
it was a modest little forward but for
the young man
it symbolized freedom and a first
success
for now he won't be able to afford a new
one
very bad very very bad
even though everything around him was
destroyed
moana doesn't want to give up
i never lose hope you can't live without
hope
that's why i came to germany because i
had no more hope left in my home country
we have to stick together and look
forward
mohammed is hoping for state aid so he
can rebuild his life
yet again